dieses haus hat schon bessere zeiten
gesehen das kollektiv sollbruchstelle
bringt nun kunst ins alte gemäuer ein
panoptikum von düster bittersüß was die
künstler verbindet möglichkeit ist hier
fehl am platz die kunst geht gemeinsam
mit dem bau unter
ich möchte dass ehrlichkeit nicht mehr
abbauen
in vielen nachtschichten hat paul wähler
dieses zimmer von der holzverkleidung
befreit was dahintersteckte ist nun teil
seiner installation
die alle funde beim rückbau vom verband
egal wo der praxis und pfeffer und die
sind alle und ines beide jänicke das
sind alles vorliegt wo der content und
schlussendlich ist ein ziemlich im
vorstand wo sich dann sogar thematisch
hitler ordner in stella clippers raum
geht es um die suche nach identität und
dem eigenen willen die transsexuelle
künstlerin und musikerin feiert hier
ihre idole velvet underground und andy
warhol
ohne auf den bau rücksicht nehmen zu
müssen
undenkbar in einem museum ich meine so
zum beispiel das loch ich habe mit grüß
ich torsten slok spitze aber schon
wissen was behindert ist und was
behinderte schwester das kwi außerdem
tasmanische tiger
das geht wenn es nacht oder wiener
helios und das stroma dazu einfach
wunderbar
aber wenn wir das jetzt im museum ich
meine die möglichkeit die überraschung
zusammen husumer geschafft und es
konnten da zu sein
kunst als eine schräge form von
sterbebegleitung für einen abbruch
liegenschaft nur zehn tage und dann ist
alles vorbei
das ist das konzept der initianten
nicole roth und jenny aro mann der ich
mache mir sehr bucher will ja genau mit
dem venture mit der geschichte vor der
hitze wie im ausland für den höchster
verabschieden
wie man auf die ort wo verschwindet wenn
tobi wiese der sich kein
verkaufsplattform die welt gesehen
die verschieden mit dem einbruch seien
stammkunden seien
kunst am sterbenden bau dieses motto hat
die modeschöpferin christa de carouge
ganz besonders inspiriert sie will
künftig keine mode mehr machen nur noch
kunst
seit sehr sehr viel verarbeiten die auf
abschied von menschen und jetzt
natürlich von der arbeit ich bin der
herr dein gott und hat sehr sehr gut wie
ich steck sie deine spiele geschichte
gefallen dass man irgendwo entdeckt es
leid gefunden hat damit greift verrottet
verstaubt und raska alle die kunst sache
mit den hosen sind gut mit dem husten
ist einfach ein wunderschöner gedanke
untergehen in schönheit und schmerz so
war es bereits beim ersten projekt der
sollbruchstelle an der löwenstrasse in
zürich leichte wehmut kommt auch jetzt
auf jetzt wo es hier in zollikon mit dem
museum auf zeit zu ende geht
ein kunstobjekt
das wird jedoch nicht
die ausstellung ist bereits
vergangenheit
das haus hat noch ein paar wochen tage
frist
bevor die bagger auffahren